The One PIece Manga just introduced something to
the story, that I would not have expected even
in my wildest dreams. Bonney and Luffy have just
discovered an actual light saber inside Vegapunk’s
laboratory. So now there is an actual possibility
that we will see a light saber wielding Zoro in
the story of one Piece. It also might be even more
foreshadowing that Luffy and his crew will go to
space at some point in the story, based on all the
moon and rocket related technology we have seen in
One PIece. On top of that, Bonney has turned Luffy
into a 70 year old man, something that Eiichiro
Oda had drawn before in an SBS. Not the successful
pirate king version, that looks like Garp,
but Luffy if he doesn’t achieve his dream. Kuma
might be the second known character next to King
who is part of the Lunarian race and while Zoro
is mistrusting Vegapunk Nr. 2, Vegapunk Nr. 1
is in contact with the revolutionaries, talking
about his death. Meanwhile, Aokiji is confirmed
as an official member of Blackbeard’s crew for
the very first time, looting whole cake island,
while Law and his men put up a way better fight
against Teach, than any of us could have imagined.
Does Law have a chance to win this after all? What
is Vegapunk's true goal here? Is Luffy’s new form,
foreshadowing for a dark future? And most
importantly: Will we see triple wielding
darth zoro as an official part of the story? Turns
out, we might already know the answer to all this.
The current Egghead island arc is the first
part of One PIece’s final saga. And just as Oda
promised, it has been setting new standards for
the story already. Currently there are two ongoing
plot lines running in parallel: The straw hats’
adventure inside the Headquarters of the genius
scientist Vegapunk and the epic clash between
Blackbeard and Law. Teach has ambushed Luffy’s
brother in arms to get his hands on Kaido’s
poneglyph after his defeat. We have found out that
Blackbeard didn’t have any of the road poneglyphs
necessary to find the final island laugh tale yet,
but instead had waited patiently and equipped his
crew with the most powerful devil fruits in order
to simply take the information from someone else.
They could do the dirty work for him. As a result,
a lot is at stake in this fight: Aokiji
and Van Augur have gotten their hands on
Big Mom’s road poneglyph as well as Pudding. So
Teach already has 1 stone that Law hasn’t, plus
someone who can actually decipher its meaning.
Should Law Lose, Blackbeard will not only have
the legendary OP OP no mi in his grasp, but also
get the 2 poneglyphs Law has from Zou and Wano,
which would have him draw even with Luffy. Plus 3
hostages, Law, Pudding and Kobe to draw out Luffy
one he gets his hands on the fourth. I’ll get
to how this fight is going in just a moment.
Meanwhile, it seems like the straw hats have
had a much better draw with their arrival at
egghead island. They most likely aren’t only
about to get a whole lot of sacred knowledge
about devil fruits and the history of the world
from Vegapunk, but quite possibly also receive
some decisive power upgrades on top. After all,
the island and its technology are 500 year ahead
of the rest of the world, which Oda has shown us
in the form of countless advanced technologies,
including the light saber. A weapon that clearly
is inspired by star wars. And we all know how
deadly and powerful a weapon this is in that
universe. So the big question is: Is this simply
a funny little easter egg Oda has thrown into
the story, or does this futuristic weapon serve
a much more important role for the plot here?
After all we do have a powerful swordsmaster
who wants to cut anything. Or could this serve an
even bigger purpose? Let’s look at the evidence.
The lightsaber in itself already begs to be
used in my opinion just looking at it and seeing
Luffy’s reaction to it. It definitely wouldn’t be
the first futuristic weapon related to Vegapunk
in the straw hat crew. After all, as you can see
in these panels, we have Franky’s cyborg powers,
Nami’s climat tact and Sanji’s genetic
modifications. Would Eiichiro Oda ever
turn Zoro into the One Piece version of a
Jedi or Sith? Well, we don’t have to wonder,
because he has already done that. Twice: This
is official artwork Oda did in 1999 for the
release of The Phantom Manice with Zoro as anakin
skywalker. And then, in 2015 for the release of
the force awakens, he drew the straw hats as star
wars figures. Again Zoro as a Jedi slash sith. And
of course we have all the other space related
technology in One PIece. We have seen a ton of
rocket shaped objects in the lab. There are ships
capable of space travel, like Enel’s arch maxime
and of course we already know from Enel’s cover
story that there used to be a whole civilization
on one of the one piece moons with advanced
technology. And of of course: Space pirates.
Now does all this prove that Zoro will start
yielding a lightsaber for the rest of the series?
well, yeah it could. Eiichiro Oda has been a
big Sci Fi and star wars fan and taken a lot
of inspiration from it for his own story. When you
look at the reflection of this TV in Oda’s office,
you can see a live size model of R2D2
parked under a shelf. He also has a life
size terminator by the way, in case you were
curious where the inspiration for franky came
from. Of course the lightsaber could also just
end up being a small token of his appreciation
for the star wars story or simply a gadget that
Zoro or some other character uses in the story,
but it could mean much much more than this. As you
know, Oda usually doesn’t just draw attention to
things for no reason. The connection with Zoro
is quite obvious too: Lightsaber or laser sword
and the crew’s swordsman. Oda clearly thought
along the same lines as well, drawing Zoro as
a force wielder more than just once and as far
back as 1999. It’s obviously something he would
like to draw in his story. It might just be
the upgrade that Zoro has been waiting for,
looking for a unique weapon that truly can
cut anything and would allow for completely
new techniques and powers from here on out. And
while i find it unlikely that he will trade in
all of his traditional blades for lightsabers, he
might simply have this as a special fourth weapon
from now on. Or he could keep it safe until he
needs it. For example, in case that the straw
hats ever went to space. Because as you’ve seen,
there are a lot of things hinting at this. There
is actually quite a lot of evidence out there,
that Laugh Tale itself may be located on the moon,
but that’s a whole different video. Let me know if
you’d like to see that. To stick with the evidence
so far, we do know that there are space pirates,
similar to what we have in star wars, there is an
ancient and lost city slash temple of an advanced
civilisation on the moon, again similar to star
wars and all of its ancient history and lore.
And even if this is stretching it a little bit,
i know, but you could make the case that Haki
and the force are not all to different either.
just like the force, you can use Haki to control
living things and increase your fighting ability,
while its strength is dependent on the users
strength of will and training. I mean Rayleigh is
as Obi Wan a character as it gets when he teaches
Luffy haki. So should the story one day take us
to space, a lightsaber or three would really be
the only appropriate weapon for Zoro. And now
we know that it exists. Which i think is a win no
matter what way you look at it. Vegapunk is really
adding endless new possibilities to the story
and hopefully the crew will leave with a bunch of
power upgrades. But what really is Vegapunk up to?
Well, the manga just told us a little bit more.
We know that Dr. Vegapunk is not just one person,
but an entity consisting of one original body and
6 clones. And while we don’t quite know yet how
it works, each of these 6 versions of vegapunk
can think and act independently with their own
name, personality and agenda. If you want a detail
breakdown of each of the 6’s inspirations
and possible research goals, i made a whole
video about that you can check out. But for this,
let’s look at the 3 vegapunks we have met so far:
Vegapunk Nr. 1 Shaka, based on a famous Zulu king.
Vegapunk nr. 2, lilith, based on Adam’s first
wife, who was banished from paradise and turned
into the arch demon. And Vegapunk nr.5 Atlas,
who is based on the titan who was sentenced to
carrying the heavens on his shoulders. Shaka
seems to have a lot of authority, as he is able to
command lilith to bring the remaining straw hats
to him. He also is in contact to Dragon, finally
confirming the connection between Vegapunk and the
revolutionaries we all have been speculating
about. Lilith meanwhile seems to be quite
agressive and battle hungry. She wanted to get
rid of the straw hats the moment she saw them.
Zoro has decided to protect the Sunny with Brook,
because he doesn’t trust Lilith. And atlas seems
to have a quite simple and kind personality
so far, which seems to clash with her trait
of violence. We haven’t seen the remaining
3 vegapunks nor the original one so far.
Now obviously, we are still very early in this
arc. We don’t really know yet how the entire
Vegapunk with 7 bodies thing really works and
what relationship they have with each other.
But based on the evidence we have gotten so
far, I really like the idea that since each
Vegapunk can make their own decisions with their
own personality, each of them could have different
agendas too. Shaka for instance, could be the
Vegapunk that has been feeding information to
the revolutionaries and helping them with Kuma.
Meanwhile, a character like Lilith could be loyal
to the world government, while maybe again another
one might become friends with pirates like Luffy.
The answer to who’s side Vegapunk is on, could
simply be everybody’s and nobody’s. And i find
that a very intriguing premise for this entire
arc. That could mean that we have factions of
Vegapunk fighting amongst each other. It could
be a little bit like the pixar movie inside out,
where Vegapunk has personified different parts of
himself. I like this idea a lot, because we still
don’t really have a clear objective or villain for
this arc. The straw hats have no goal right now.
No one to meet up with. No one to defeat yet.
Just sightseeing basically. So having Vegapunk
be the villain AND the ally in this arc would
be fantastic. Especially with CP0 in the mix.
On top of that we have the reveal that Kuma is not
only Bonnies father and a former revolutionary,
but also from a special race,
which given his dark skin most
likely means that Kuma is a Lunarian
just like king. This would of course
explain why Vegapunk wanted to experiment
on him, like he did with King, who escaped,
and why the pacifista have now evolved into the
Seraphim, that have strong Lunarian properties.
At the same time, Luffy has now been turned
into the 70 year old version of himself, that
Oda drew as the ‘bad timeline’. In this
reality luffy never fulfills his dream
to become pirate king and ends up bitter.
Does this mean that Luffy’s future right
now means that he will not reach his dream? I
like the idea a lot that at some point Bonney
turns Luffy old again and this time he’s
the successful version that looks like garp,
symbolizing that luffy is on the right path
again. Maybe, it’s because of Luffy’s biggest
rival Blackbeard threatening to catch up to
him and taking out one of his biggest allies.
The fighting sequence between Law and Teach
is really something else. We all kind of knew
that Law was strong, but he’s holding his ground
here much better than I anticipated. He clearly
has learned a lot from his fight with Kaido and
Big Mom. Law uses his awakened abilities quite
comfortably, managing to land some serious
hits on Blackbeard, who counters with both
of his devil fruit abilities. I’m especially
surprised to see that Law’s crew is holding
themselves against Blackbeard’s crew. I did
not see that coming, especially because Law’s
crew was not at all involved in the raid on
Onigashima. Turns out they can actually fight.
Now I will stick to my opinion that
Law, despite how strong he has gotten,
has no chance of winning this, simply because
it would make no sense story wise. However, I do
believe that he might manage to get away instead
of getting captured. One way or the other I do
think that Blackbeard will get his hands on Law’s
two poneglyphs here, really raising the stakes
between him and Luffy to as high as possible. If
not now then when will Teach get those 2 stones.
He has planned all this so carefully that he
really can’t afford to lose here. And in case
you’re curious what Blackbeard’s genius plan has
been, you should really check out that video next.